coming up next and if he's going to
provide that for me and all I've got to
do is pop up for you so I'll sit at home
why not to be honest you know I am a
working woman and I've got a child it's
stressful we can complain about the
video games but how many girls are on
social media for hours
we're just as bad you know you know what
you're right if you want to heal to have
a fruitful relationship but that's not
going to be toxic that's not going to
have any of the repeated patterns just
have that discipline when you'll
probably be like actually you know what
I do really like you as a person but let
me get to a place where I know that I'm
strong with in who I am I'm not dealing
with the same whatever from the last
person and bringing that into the new
person because all that's going to
happen is yeah you're going to be in the
same predicament yeah it's just gonna be
a different story certainly Elon Musk
needed a woman to get to worry about
Richmond get to where they're at going
regardless of whether or not there was
by giving dog eat dog I'm trying to get
better I've been trying these interview
I've been trying
next question
um could you guys
respect a man that you make more money
than
starting here and then go around
and just just uh just okay and just to
give a little preface
that means if he says quick quit your
job tomorrow I have a plan that you'd
listen
go ahead
um
I wouldn't respect a man that I make
more money than
um but
if I had a man that makes more money
than me and is you know well put
together
um I can see that I can trust his
judgment and I know that you know he's
got good morals he's
um he's got good faith yes if he says
stop working that's what I want I want
to sit at home I want to paint my toes I
want to look cute I want to you know
drive a nice car and
um have maids and all of that and if
he's going to provide that for me and
all I've got to do is pop a couple of
Utes out sit at home why not why not I'm
sorry
I don't think that's the typical stand
on Mom's experience
a lot of work are you a stay-at-home mom
yeah I am I am now is that where your
life is like no
I wish no I'm talking about you know the
the dream the dream yeah that I do
um but
you could still be a stay-at-home wife
on a more normal salary it just means
cutting off like going down if he can
pay our rent and put food on the table
and do everything that you know I would
be working to provide half of absolutely
fine I can do without the maid I can do
without you know all of that let me just
focus on our home you bring the money in
and I'll make our home a home and that
way I will be more happier because to be
honest you know I am a working woman and
I've got a child it's stressful you know
that morning rush to get that little
four-year-old ready and she don't
understand why I'm rushing and she's you
know my name only and I've got a Russia
get her in the car drop her off I've
done a whole shift before I've gone to
work and then I've got to deal with
people that I work with and then you
know hard stop five o'clock I need to
stop this meeting I need to rush out to
you know to my colleagues you know I
might look like you know I don't put any
meetings in their diary after five
o'clock because you know she's a single
mom and there's that stigma that you've
got to deal with so
the short answer yeah okay
um I think I could I think
in reality that I would have to
I don't think it would be easy to
but I would work at it because I don't
like especially with the way it is to
live now I would not leave an
opportunity to make more money
um because my man doesn't
but I will always strive to respect him
um and leave him to do the providing so
essentially if I bought more money into
the house that's just more spending
money in my opinion I would allow him
like I would leave him to his role
basically yeah let me ask you this what
is it like being a stay-at-home mom
wow
do you know what it's it's fine it's
good because
to me I like raising my children is my
priority and looking after my home is my
priority everything else is extra
but as long as I can give myself the
space to do the extra I'm I'm happier
that way if my whole life was just at
home with the kids and maintaining my
house I don't know how happy I would be
only because I had a lifestyle before
getting married that I I liked and so I
think here I have the best of both
worlds but I think and actually so I'm
confused are you not a stay-at-home mom
I am a stay-at-home mom but I I do bits
on the side so okay I yeah so um I'm a
stepmom coach yeah but my house doesn't
depend on the money I make all the money
I make it's fun so you work from home
yes I'm I'm yeah I'm always at home yeah
I come out to to do a speaking gig or
something like that yeah
okay so yeah I would strive to the space
but he will always be the provider and
I'm okay with that whatever that looks
like okay and just like you said also to
her you know how you were saying
um you can have a man on like a normal
wage and still be a say at home mom he
doesn't have to be earning thousands
that is very true like I essentially
what we say in our cultures cut your
coat according to your size whatever my
husband makes our life I will maintain
our life according to what he makes and
as long as Anna says he's our met
there's really there shouldn't be a
complaint
I like you yeah thank you I like you too
um okay so could you respect a man that
you make more than yes
the answer is yes however I want to see
him
being ambitious he has to have a plan he
has to be someone that gets up in the
morning no that's not that that's not
the guy you're dating no
that's like that's like the women trying
to change men no he's he's making let's
say what's whatever the average salary
is here 35 000 pounds a year it depends
on his he will always be making thirty
five thousand dollars a year okay this
isn't build a man but what kind of
person is he the kind of guy that wakes
up and plays video games and just you
guys he's the kind that he's he goes to
work okay and makes 35 000 a year and
then comes home sometimes he plays video
games sometimes he doesn't the same way
you know it's like they we can complain
about the video games but how many girls
are on social media for hours
we're just as bad no you know what
you're right
I think I could because I've been in
that situation and I've been very happy
with
that okay why aren't you with him he's
in Australia oh oh no so this was recent
yeah okay I don't know what he makes
it's none of my business but I know he's
not like the richest guy in the world
but he's lovely and he actually made me
feel safe in every way so how do you
know that you earn more than him I don't
but if I did I'd be okay with it because
he was that wonderful
okay okay so yeah sounds like you need
to go back to Australia finish your
healing well uh that was the plan not
for him though but I would like to see
him again 100 oh do you think you're
healed enough though
um wait I'm confused so when was the
okay so it wasn't the the old guy eight
months ago
yeah that was in June okay and then when
did the the Australia guy come in
literally this month oh oh and he left
to Australia no I was in Australia she
went away to Australia for six weeks see
this is why when men sleep clear with
everything the guy say so this is why
when guys say like you're healing they
just think you I mean they don't have
anything yeah you're just sleeping with
other dudes
um no because it wasn't quite like that
it took me a long time to even go on a
date with someone like it wasn't until I
went to Australia I considered that I
was just completely
red but you told me you were healing
earlier in Australia yeah and now you're
telling me you met the guy in Australia
it's no it's no hate to you I'm just no
it's fine I'm just observing he's a
Healer and that that if I'm honest
because I said that to him because he
was going through his own thing which I
won't discuss on here that's his
business and I was going through mine
and I said to him for whatever reason I
walked into your life and you walked
into mine because it was an accident you
know I was walking down the street she
goes oh you met him on the street what
happened was I just come back from the
gym I was in a bad mood I smell I was
covered in sweat I was spotty I was like
you know on my period so I was like
bloated and I did not look appealing at
all and this stunning man walks towards
me and when I fancy someone I get shy
and I just looked down
and he starts talking to me and I'm just
like in my head I'm like why today why
today
and then he's like you should smile you
know it looks good on you and then we
were just talking
and um
I felt really good around this person he
made me feel safe there's something
about his energy that just made me feel
really good
and you were able to trust him
it was more
I know that sounds wild because even I
look back and I think how did I do that
to an extent yeah because I said to him
what are you doing later let's go out
it was me that initiated it and then
when he went in to kiss me he said he
asked my permission he's this is after
the date he said can I kiss you you know
he was asking my permission he was
respectful of my boundaries he was you
know
but you know how you said that you were
going through your stuff and he was
going through his stuff you said that
about your ex the one who was obviously
dealing with anorexia you said
um he his traumas and neural traumas
like were able to go together and now
you're saying basically the same thing
this guy yeah yeah it's because I'm
aware I'm not a perfect person but don't
you think that you said you're you're
healing right yeah if you're healing and
then you're now meeting this guy and
you're acknowledging the fact that
you're going through your ish he's going
through his ish and we've meshed
together you're acknowledging the fact
that you're entering the same pattern
again yeah just because the guy is you
know but it's always when you're not
looking for someone they just pop up and
then you click I can't explain it but
they're not denying what you're saying
though you're right but don't don't you
think you should just not that you
should but
I guess what I'm saying is if you want
to heal to have a fruitful relationship
that's not going to be toxic that's not
going to have any of the repeated
patterns just have that discipline with
yourself and be like actually you know
what I do really like you as a person
but let me get to a place where I know
that I'm strong with in who I am I'm not
dealing with the same whatever from the
last person and bringing that into the
new person because all that's going to
happen is yeah you're going to be in the
same predicament yeah it's just going to
be a different story I wouldn't say it's
a personal thing on me I'm definitely
strong in who I am but you're right I'm
definitely not over what happened and I
I appreciate what you said thank you I
just feel the only professional here I
don't feel self healing is not healing
but how do how I have it sounds like you
ran away to Australia but you can't run
away from yourself how yeah you know
what that's right that's true because I
caught myself crying in a new city about
the same [__] sorry ish I remember
therapy yeah
is it a is it a male or a female
therapist it's a male oh wow yeah no
luck
he's amazing no honestly no he's he's so
sad about it I'm still yeah but how do
you turn that off like every healing you
need acceptance first you need to accept
that it's happening
I have accepted it it's just because I'm
speaking about it on a club do you still
like look up in Social Media stuff I
tell you from the day that I broke up
with him I've never stalked him I'm too
proud I would never do that I'm Still
Loving counseling
I don't want to answer that okay but
you're right there is more work to be
done I'm aware of that it's just because
for me to come on a public platform and
speak about it it's like quite raw for
me still do you know what it is
sometimes when you're not ready yourself
the universe just keeps giving you the
same person in different forms that's so
true you're attracting the same kind to
yourself so you need to be alone and
happy within yourself and then put
something that you obviously think is
for you and good for you will come but
you're not ready so that's why the world
isn't bringing you someone I don't I
think right now your subconscious is
just is saying actually I need to be
back in something I need to know because
I wasn't even looking for that single I
do I love being single and I will only
laughing I send her subconscience no
because I wasn't looking for him I was
walking down the street I told him to go
meet you at the bar because I enjoyed
his company I'm in Australia you're just
contradicting yourself
how did you know his company by him just
saying hi though do you know what I mean
because I felt good in his presence and
I'm in a new city across in the night
you know that that feeling that you felt
that safe feeling yeah did you have that
with the last person who was your friend
and you just had that feeling and he was
like oh I like this yeah yeah so you
haven't actually gotten over that yeah
no you're right that that same feeling
that same kick that you got from the
last one you still get him from this you
know what it sounds like you're addicted
to that feeling yeah you know what
you're probably right can I ask you can
choose not to answer yeah you're quite
personal but before both of these um
have you suffered with stuff within
yourself and then you're kind of using
these yeah to patch that up yeah okay
probably most likely
but that's the first step is
acknowledgment yeah
[Music]
okay where were we in the room with the
money question
okay go ahead if my man was making
um less than me
um yeah yeah significantly less than I
was earning more he would still be my
man probably it doesn't really matter to
me I love the person for the person if
it stopped me from doing things and
living the life that I wanted to live
then I'm not with the right person like
if I love someone I love them for them
I'm not really materialistic about stuff
like that is there a minimum
what figure yeah I mean because yeah to
be honest let's be honest because he's
unemployed if he's unemployed for two
years you're out yeah probably and I
hope you help you yeah
he's on him for two years I'm out but so
there has to be like a minimum what
would you roughly say it is
I couldn't I don't know what people earn
and not shift work I couldn't tell you
how much you'd like him to bring I'm a
week or a month not shift work like what
would you like him to bring I'm a month
yeah in a month
two grand three grand
four grand remember you you listen if he
says quit whatever the amount that
sustains us to like be happy but I don't
need like big flashy things to be happy
we'd be happy living in the Caravan
I guess what about what about the Box on
the corner over here no there's someone
there's there's like a couple people in
these boxes over there oh yeah down
there in it yeah
they've got this box set in the roads
I've seen it I don't think I could but
money doesn't determine like the person
for me if that makes sense
I don't know if that answers your
question I no I don't know
there's no minimum like come on no
minimum I don't know thinking about that
I don't know what people earn for you
what like to have all your Necessities
met
um
do you mind your own yeah I live online
okay so you know what it takes to
sustain you yeah do you want him to be a
provider basically because if you do you
know you have to know your minimum
surely surely unless you don't mind
providing for yourself then it doesn't
matter at all
yeah can we not come together was that
not an option
is earning less than me yeah so I I'm
I'm saying at what point do you respect
his decision making
so like if he said quit your job
tomorrow I have a plan I'll listen but
if he's a bum and hasn't worked in two
years why the hell would you do that
yeah I would definitely not listen so so
there's a minimum point right yeah
there's a minimum point where and it
doesn't have to be exact you know just
just a rough figure where you would
listen to what he says
I want to see I couldn't tell you I
couldn't tell you a figure okay what
about
30 30 000 pounds would you listen
is that the minimum people just go off
like what it takes to sustain yourself
and then could you live on a thousand
pound a month if he's bringing in like
between three and four thousand three
and four thousand I think yeah that's
fine a year
oh yeah that's nice that's fine it's
modernizing some people I like it yeah
okay um what about you would you date a
guy that makes less than you I would
date a guy that
um
yeah I would but he would have to be
able to like pay the bills and what's
your what's your minimum um I would say
for Grand because that's like enough to
like pay bills rent or mortgage
um can't know that sort of stuff okay
what about you
[Music]
um
I think I would respect him
I don't believe you why don't you
believe me
um oh gosh what's your minimum okay my
minimum
I'll be comfortable with let's say 3K a
month I think that's fine okay to bring
in
um I think it's all down to I don't know
if it kind of relates to the question
that you're asking I think it's just all
down to ambition if he's a bum no she
said no no that's what he's gonna say
this is the problem with women she said
that she's gonna read it it's gonna be a
hiring her one day no he's not oh
he's happy at his job he loves it he
loves it so it doesn't mean he's lazy
maybe he's like a I don't know do police
officers yeah Postman do police officers
yeah yeah oh God I mean I worked at
McDonald's it's all right
I think my Approach generally is a job
is a job as long as it's keep making you
comfortable then I will respect that
full stop yeah I think that's just it oh
yeah but I mean in terms of like respect
I mean if we're living together and we
have a family and I meant to like
respect all your decision making
if you're not earning at least to cover
what it takes I mean it's like okay if
you're dating a guy that makes 250 000 a
year pounds or whatever it is here
um if he says quit when
I get yeah that's so much money it's
when like when do you want me to but at
some point like it switches to where you
give him more control
because if a bum tells you to do that
you're not going to do it yeah if it
hasn't worked in two years he says quit
you're like what I mean I can all agree
on that though yeah yeah which we all
agree on but like I'm just asking
roughly around what point is it that you
respect his decision making
like roughly four grand a month okay
that's a good question are these are
things that you wouldn't even ask
yourself oh yes I'm actually kind of
glad that I'm here I think if you want
to get married you kind of have to do
them yeah yeah because it also depends
how many kids you want yeah so like how
much does each kid cost yeah you need to
think about these things while entering
a relationship especially if you're
going to merge into one I feel like
women do don't they yeah like even on
first dates exactly like what would our
wedding look like yeah
what area are we gonna move to and the
man is just right there looking at the
stage yeah but we're at five years into
it she's like oh today's a nice day
she's like we could have two kids
the white picket fence is there yeah are
you think about that career ladder as
well all of it yeah 100 and you look on
glass at all I think women like for
fantasize a lot oh yeah and think way
into the future that's good because
that's how they help men like Blossom
like that's how women are health system
in because men are very like and women
are like oh but you could do it this way
and this way and like they flower the
seeds that make it grow women have to
like think outside the box because men
are very a matter of fact which is good
and that's why the woman and the man
works together yeah yeah it's like that
quote
that's I think it says something like um
behind every great man is an even better
woman or something Have you heard that
one yeah oh yeah that's the most
[__] quote ever I don't think it
should be even better but I think great
women should be there instead but it
kind of oh just the woman that cares
yeah yeah this is woman just because
every man is this woman his woman Elon
Musk needed a woman to get to where he's
at Richmond get to where they're going
regardless of whether or not they have a
girlfriend dog eat dog for sure it's
like I mean like the guys that are going
somewhere they're gonna go somewhere
whether or not you're there it's just
like women just like to take credit for
doing nothing yeah
I guess I listen I think unless you're
looking at having kids men can just
pretty much
do anything whereas they don't need
emotional support well they do yeah they
don't need it as much as women like I
don't think they need it like women like
to talk about stuff more they're with
their friends what do they talk about
talk about guys talk about feelings talk
about look men are just like straight to
the point we wiggle around a bit more
but it works together
um
I like the chorus yeah
and they're not even you're not even
doing it this time you've got a whole
chorus here
they always roast me in the comments
obviously they're laughing because I
think normally it's Pearl and every
woman is doing it I've been trying to
get better I've been trying to use
interview I've been trying
it's like it's a tick I can't no it's
just a thing in it because all the women
are doing it one person made a comment
and I'm just saying listen to the choir
and the choir said
I love that Auntie oh what do you think
I've never been out of a man that's uh
more than me never never
and I've respected every single one hmm
why do you think that is different than
a lot of women nowadays
I just don't really care how much I am
because no
I really imagine is that when I'm out of
a man he's a man so I don't
I don't pay for anything I'd have to put
my hand in my pocket even the man that
I've got now
mm-hmm
still got more than him he's got my I
must admit he's got more cash than me
I've got more assets than him
but no I can't I'd have to put my hand
in my pocket for nothing yeah I think as
long as I don't have to put my hand in
my pocket then yeah I have no problems
what is what is the minimum
person Panama if I can make it work you
know our camper oh oh you know I can
make it wow
so if these people if these women are
here are saying oh they need to do this
oh the man can't afford that you know
what I mean check yourself do with a
thousand pounds a month how would you
spot that up I'm just curious I've got
wholesalers yeah I mean it's different
because all right then if I had them if
you live in London with a thousand
pounds a month I can live in before I
was living I can do it on 1500. okay
because like 500 is towards with the
mortgage yeah kids are not expensive it
all depends do you know what right it
all depends on what you want them to
wear but nowadays you'll find that
a five pound t-shirt is not going to
cost you 50 pounds for the kid or
because of the name or the stamp on it
and that's what brings things up or you
know eating out you know you and a
burger buy some mince meat and teach
your kids how to make a burger
you know no eating out
no
a thousand pound is covering bills it's
doing me now
wow you know I honestly have the same I
had the same thought yo she took me she
took me how much did you say was 35
pounds it was 30 pounds 30 pounds 30
pounds she said A week for two people
yeah she told me she could get a week's
worth of groceries on 30 pounds I didn't
believe her and go to the market yeah
she took me she took me no we went to
the supermarket we didn't even go to a
market yeah you can do it you
but yeah I I didn't believe her I was
like there is no way there's no way but
yeah 30 pounds you have to look for the
stickers the clearance stickers
in the morning we just went in there we
just we just popped in there and we
picked up about four things of stickers
but everything else wasn't was it was
about four things of stickers in the
middle of the day yeah now in the eve
was it in the evening
but if it wasn't bad food it really
wasn't no yeah but you have to even
though
this month to cover a whole month
including toiletries laundry alcohol and
everything for the month a thousand
pounds
for the month I'm talking about all the
alcohol as well well laundry toiletries
electric toothbrush everything Frozen
pan then that's it
yeah I'm gonna watch it sometimes it's
fine
I'll show I show you my tricks yeah I'm
sorry I need a few tips I'm sewing it I
do you guys think that corn you know you
know what that stands for okay do you
guys think that corn is cheating no
yes no yes
Roxy does it in front I want to see
watches it in front of me or I know he's
there watching if it's hidden it's
cheating if it's like yeah you want to
watch it it's like it's like watching
another movie I'm watching it though but
I think if it's hidden I think it's
cheating because for you to hide it site
must be wrong yeah I agree don't lie
about it fine yeah I feel like you can
fit together
no I don't want to do that but really do
you think it's cheating no that's
definitely I just feel like he wouldn't
want to do it in front of you why not I
don't know no don't do it in front of me
I don't want I don't mean that in front
of you I mean like if he's there
watching that he loves me never watching
the TV and yeah he's in one room and
he's watching it and he coming oh you're
watching that rubbish again it's like
it's nothing to me but you wouldn't get
mad as long as he's not he's open with
it yeah would anyone here be mad if
their husband watched or boyfriend
watched corn sorry can I just say
something it all depends on what kind it
is if it's that sick perverted kind then
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
I mean if it's like regular normal yeah
yeah any I'll be upset I don't think I'd
be mad or be concerned because what is
it what's what are you seeking from this
variety
but then again to me that's a concern
for me because what Verizon why do you
want variety let's just try this is why
naturally
I'm not saying all men cheat but men
naturally want variety you're telling me
okay you could take the best man in the
world if he had a Bus full of models
waiting for him every day when he got
home every single day begging to sleep
with it mostly guys are gonna fail
fair enough but I'm I'm putting my self
in it
if you want variety it's a concern if
you if you cannot exercise self-control
it's a concern
if I am to exercise self-control and you
don't give yourself
that same parameter is a concern I'm not
saying I'll be angry but this is
something to iron out it's not something
that oh this is how you are that's your
makeup that's fine because I know what I
want and as far as I'm concerned on the
foundational like morals principles
Sanders we match and so if we're no
longer matching it's an even bigger
concern and now we're talking about the
longevity of our relationship I don't
think it means that you don't match no
no but it's up because I know what I
would like and I say what you was like
what is that not not to watch that and
if if
you're telling me these are the reasons
why you watch it less eyeing out those
reasons so you don't have to if you feel
like the reason is just uh I just like
yeah and it doesn't mean he's doing it
every day or even every week knows why
they like it but everyone knows why they
like what they like no one just likes it
and I'm not sure but that's like but
that's like a female point of view like
to men it's just like a reaction they
don't think that much
but then that's not why then that's
that's fine we don't have to but it's
almost like asking men not to be men but
no not necessarily because in my
experience I have what I have not
experienced that do you understand so I
can't even speak to it because it's not
like I've been with a man that could
explain his side of it all I can say is
from my once and if this is how you are
that's fine I'm not gonna like say
change it's you're just not for me yeah
it sounds like you're not it you haven't
created a space where they could even
come to tell you that they want you is
that it sounds like if they do it's in
private like they wouldn't even tell you
oh it's effective and this is what I'm
saying I wouldn't get angry to me it
would be a concern so if you came to me
or I caught you I'm not gonna be oh my
no no it's like okay let's sit down and
talk about it like why why why can't you
feel like you like this or whatever and
like if if you like this is how I am and
I can't really explain it or whatever
I have the right to say but I don't like
this I don't I don't have to compromise
on that so hang on can I just say
something because from what tell me if
I'm wrong yeah you're talking about
if like now if you found him watching or
if he suddenly decided yeah but
what I would say yeah and what I think
you're saying is that yeah this is you
wouldn't be with somebody that does it
anyway yeah and then if he happens to be
doing it there's a problem yeah and that
I feel the same way I mean if I if I
know that my man does it and I'm with
him I knew that he'd done it before I
got with him but everyone with a man and
then suddenly he starts doing it what's
going on why all of a sudden you started
you never showed it and I think that's
what you're trying to say yeah because
trying to change an individual is futile
to me okay especially if you do not see
an issue
like I don't have the energy to try and
make you see or even see it from my
point of view if you don't you don't but
I don't have to be I don't have to take
it do you understand or or like I do
have the choice I can I can just
tolerate it like okay this is like I can
tolerate it but my point is is then I
have a choice but before me making that
choice I want to sit down and understand
if I had a man and it wasn't open about
in the first place and I found him doing
it
you know what kind can you imagine you
know I've been with you for x amount of
years and you're saying I've always
watched it and I've been like yeah
but then that's choosing to hide it no
yeah that's when I may get angry yeah I
agree but if it's happening
we're going to talk about it okay I just
think a lot of times like from the men's
point of view it's like
we want them to be exclusive to us which
is like compromising on their mating
strategy strategy which is to spread
their seed but on the same time like
when they try to watch and I'm not
saying you specifically I don't know
your marriage yeah but like when when
you tell them that they can't even watch
corn and that's cheating too it's like
well what do you want from me what can I
do so I just set them straight whatever
they doing and then I'll try it with you
yeah
Auntie's ready to meet them in the
middle yeah I'll attract with you you
know I mean like you want to pick up
some tips but they're not going to watch
it let's let's have a go what's another
freaky stuff you know man don't slap me
either
yeah
I feel like corn has saved a lot of
marriages I've had a partner show me
something and be like
let's try this
really yeah were you down or were you
mad she was down
she was down I was down but I it was in
a case where I didn't know that he
wasn't watching it because I knew he
watched it or he'd sometimes be like oh
look look at this like he'd send it to
me be like I don't know how I'd feel my
partner showed me really ever sent you
your friends and let's try this tonight
I don't know I feel like I would be like
and I'm not saying I would be against it
but I I don't know
I think that's about I don't know
obviously everyone's different but to me
for me personally there's boundaries you
can be watching it and doing all this
but if you're putting more attention on
that then me then it's an issue
[Music]